hello and welcome back to aniko today
we're going to be talking about an anime
series called prison school out of the
thousand girls attending hachimitsu
academy five best friends kiyoshi gakuto
shingo joe and andre are the only boys
in the school kiyoshi meets chiyo an
avid sumo fan and becomes the first of
the five to have talked to a girl they
decide to go to a sumo tournament later
kiyoshi's friends formulate a plan to
record a video of the girl's baths when
he drops his phone inside the bathroom
he sneaks in to retrieve it chio
discovers kiyoshi but mistakes him for
her friend mayumi however the
underground student council the usc
catches his friends and ultimately
kiyoshi is also caught by their
president mari as punishment the five
are sentenced to one month in the
school's prison where kiyoshi becomes
awestruck at the guy's masochistic
outlooks after the constant abuse by the
vice president meiko shortly after maeko
enlists the help of hana the usc
secretary to oversee the boys after
kiyoshi tends to a baby crow he meets
chio and promises he'll meet her at the
sumo match as hannah attempts to urinate
beneath him however akron knocks him off
the tree branch and he witnesses hana
urinating much to her embarrassment
maeko and the others rushed to the scene
of a crying hannah and the boys are
ordered back to the prison as mari and
her father the school's chairman discuss
the prisoners mari tells the boys that
they have up to three hours of free time
on the weekend including furloughs
inspiring kioshi and the others to
become model prisoners as mari drops off
the new usc guidebook to the chairman's
office she stumbles on some porn on his
computer deciding to punish the boys by
removing their free time after kiyoshi
formulates a plan to break out by
breaking a hole behind a refuse shed
gakuto starts exhibiting strange
behavior as hana requests that kyoshi
pees in front of her in return for
watching her pee he's saved by gakuto
who catches onto kyoshi's breakout plan
and offers him assistance in return for
three kingdom figurines available only
once every four years the next day
kakuto and kiyoshi fake a fight to have
hana kick the shed down and cover up the
hole nevertheless gaguto grants
permission for kyoshi to use the
bathroom cornered by hana a second time
kiyoshi accidentally pees on her
since the urination incident hana left
from being an overseer leaving meiko to
check up on the boys as the escape hole
grows bigger gaguto asks that kiyoshi
does a test run of the escape route on
his way back he witnesses the chairman
burying nude pictures shingo starts
feeling left out by kiyoshi and gakuto
seeing them talk frequently in
preparation for a track meet kiyoshi
kakuto and shingo are placed on
belongings watch duty but shingo
transfers with andre and joe to
miscellaneous jobs after witnessing
kyoshi and gaguto taking a shower
together thus putting shingo out of the
way kiyoshi notices a drainage pipe that
leads from the bathroom to near the
escape hole a test run results in meiko
stepping on kyoshi's butt and causing it
to bleed which shingo mistakenly claims
is a case of hemorrhoids later during it
class gaguto plans on using his audio
player to play fake defecation noises
when kyoshi is using the bathroom
however when no audio clips pop up he
decides to make his own by defecating
himself despite their efforts they find
out the hull had been patched up not
realizing the chairman did it while
reburying his photos when kiyoshi
devises another plan to sneak out by
cross-dressing kakuto aids him once more
as he intentionally strips down mari's
skirt after he goes to the usc's office
where maego shaves his hair as a
reprimand for his actions however with
his hair collected inside a bag he
reveals the real intention of shaving
his head was to have kyoshi use it as a
makeshift wig for sneaking out to prison
before the breakout kiyoshi heads out to
the school's laundry room to acquire a
uniform after gakuto manages to distract
the laundry man on the day of the track
meet he places speakers with the poop
audio inside the bathroom and sneaks out
through the drainage pipe after narrowly
escaping meiko and mari kiyoshi's sumo
day is cut short when chiyo found
gakuto's hair and the uniform which
revealed to be her own inside his bag
once kiyoshi realizes this he leaves as
well meanwhile at school as maeko
becomes fed up with his prolonged
bathroom trip she decides to confront
kiyoshi personally with the boot
speakers not working gaguto can only
watch nervously as meiko kicks down the
bathroom stall door when maeko kicks
down the stall she finds kiyoshi weeping
on the toilet much to gakuto's relief
and delight as kyoshi managed to obtain
his figurines as they leave the bathroom
however mari appears and meiko examines
kyoshi's back to find gaguto's hair and
cheo's uniform when mari's suspicions of
a breakout are confirmed kiyoshi is
thrown into solitary confinement kiyoshi
claims he acted alone while his friends
are punished with a one month extension
of their sentence and he's sentenced to
expulsion although meiko says they don't
have the authorization to carry out that
punishment mari entices kyoshi to write
his withdrawal request form however chio
appears and signs a withdrawal form
claiming that if mari were to expel
kiyoshi that she would also expel
herself as well then kiyoshi refuses to
sign the form and returns to the prison
where shingo joe and andre start
distancing themselves from him meanwhile
meiko searches the prison for
information to use against them to place
three breakouts on the boys and expel
them which is put into mari's plans for
boys expulsion operation which is
renamed destroy testicle operations in
the english dub the dto hana regroups
with mari and may go to poditio into
effect and promises to kiyoshi to enact
her revenge on him shingo becomes an
informant to the usc in exchange for
above average prison food after andre
knocks down joe's anfan by accident
which results in joe getting aggressive
towards him shingo relays this
information to mako during lunch break
shingo lures joe away from watching his
ants where one of mari's crows appears
to smash his ants as joe realizes this
he attempts to stab mari with a tree
branch when kiyoshi pushes him aside
before impaling himself in the butt
while joe is now thrown into solitary
confinement kiyoshi goes to the nurse's
office with hannah she hands him a pail
to urinate inside but after refusing to
she decides to do it on him instead
however chio arrives inside so hana and
kiyoshi hide under the bed with their
lower half exposed kiyoshi's banana
starts poking at her and hana faints
later joe is released and hannah seems
to have no recollection of the events
that went on in the infirmary although
kiyoshi has no idea of her not knowing
after a work break where he and joe may
commence kiyoshi talked about shingo and
meiko's conversation meanwhile in the
corrections office meiko tells shingo
that she will allow him free time
outside of school
shingo hangs out at a local arcade to
meet anzu another student from the
academy returning to the prison shingo
notices a tiny sword in the bathroom and
gives it to meko unbeknownst to both of
them however gaguto is searching inside
the bathroom for it as the sword is part
of the figurine later mako discovers
gakuto's figurines in the bathroom while
shingo has another outing at the arcade
and meets anzu again at the prison meiko
reveals she's in possession of gakuto's
figurines and gives him a choice to
confess to aiding kyoshi's escape and
have everyone's sentences extended again
or to spare his figurines much to
everyone's surprise he throws them on
the ground and breaks them as gakuto
personally confesses to the breakout to
his friends shingo becomes shocked to
everyone's forgiveness as punishment for
meiko not telling mari the origin of the
sword which was in her bowl of peanuts
mari gives maeko a uniform that's a size
smaller exhausted from the strain chio
takes maeko to mari's office where she
discovers the existence of dto as chio
ease drops from behind the door maori
announces the final phase of dto by
taking advantage of andre's masochistic
urges
exploiting andre slave diary mako leaves
andre without punishment for days
meanwhile meiko gives shingo more free
time outside warning that his failure to
return at 6 30 pm would result in a
breakout the other boys are assigned a
job reinforcing the prison gate crossing
paths with chio who glances at kiyoshi
with a hidden message later meiko's
voice calls out punishment time to andre
leading him to find his diary in the
corrections office which entices him to
go outside with chio's message
deciphered kiyoshi gaguto and joe head
out to warn andre but he breaks through
the fence and receives his punishment
only to be subdued by hana for a prison
break offense as meiko is outside of the
prison boundaries it's also revealed
that shingo's date with anzu was only a
way to stall for time nevertheless
shingle arrives before 6 30 with the
help of the laundry man but fails to
open the gate which the boys worked on
earlier with three breakouts in a row
now the five of them meet the chairman
to discuss their expulsion which cheo
attempts to intervene but fails to find
physical evidence of dto with two weeks
before their expulsion date the boys
formulate a plan to expose the usc's
hidden agenda when shingo mentions
evidence of dto being seen elsewhere
shingo recalls that at the corrections
office there was an email labeled dto
however andre says that the usc may have
planned ahead of time and deleted this
email despite this gaguto notes that the
email can still be recovered through a
data restoration software to take the
sell keys to access the corrections
office the boys lurian may go by staging
an arm wrestling match and berating may
go into challenging them in which she
accepts gakuto manages to sneak into the
corrections office to which he needs at
least 10 minutes to download the
software and search for the email
despite kyoshi shingo and joe's matches
barely lasting a minute each andrei
manages to almost hold out the rest of
the remaining time losing the match nine
minutes in before meiko also discovers
her keys are missing gaguto picks them
off the ground and hands them to her
before she leaves while the others
praise goku those timely return he
expresses his failure to retrieve the
deleted email only having downloaded the
software facing imminent expulsion
kiyoshi and the others reconcile with
each other before heading off to sleep
kiyoshi and the others have lost hope
except for a crazy gakuto who makes
nonsensical breakout plans meiko gives
the boys a request of choosing their
last meal gakuto is a fried grasshoppers
and rice dish proves to be so disgusting
that he breaks free of his irregular
state and inspires him with a legitimate
breakout plan after looking upon
kyoshi's note from chio he discusses the
plan with the others but they say
they're short on time to carry it out
after meiko hands them their withdrawal
papers kiyoshi suggests to write an
appeal to the chairman to have more time
for gakuto's plan to her surprise the
chairman responds back to the appeal and
it's revealed that the appeal mako had
ripped was a decoy and that kyoshi used
his knowledge of the chairman's buried
explicit photos to persuade him to come
he'll postpone the expulsion day only if
in a boobs versus buster bay kiyoshi's
preference aligns with the chairman's
meanwhile as meiko tries to eavesdrop
outside the prison hana goes berserk as
the repressed memories of her and
kiyoshi under the hospital bed surface
once again despite the chairman
declaring the expulsion postponed the
boys only have a one-day reprieve as the
usc decides on the next move hana
personally agrees to watch over the boys
on their final day kakuto's plan to
distract meiko falls apart when hannah
arrives instead kiyoshi exploits hana's
grudge and takes it upon himself to
sneak inside the corrections office as
chiyo intercepts another one of kyoshi's
messages inside his lunch tray she gets
caught by anzu who wishes to help the
boys out of expulsion later kakuto
deliberately gets stabbed in the
forehead with a fork by joe to be
bandaged by hannah in the corrections
office as gakuta returns kiyoshi goes
with hana there while chio and anzu are
outside and meiko patrols the prison
then hannah gives a plastic tube to
watch kyoshi pee in full of confidence
kyoshi strips down and manages to unlock
the back door but drops to the ground
after getting kneed by hana she prepares
to pee on him until maeko's apprehension
alarms hana who locks the door again
much to the boy's relief anzu was the
one that was caught in not chio
sacrificing herself so chiyo could get
inside as hannah holds the door she then
kisses kyoshi stating that stealing his
first kiss away from chio is her revenge
against him
chia waits at the back door of the
corrections office where kiyoshi and
hana's confrontation is taking place as
hana goes in for another kiss kyoshi
counter-attacks by sticking his tongue
inside hannah's mouth completely
shocking hana and resulting in a profuse
nosebleed she leaves the correction
office and chio comes inside as kiyoshi
returns to the prison hana allows gaguto
and joe to use the bathroom before the
five of them head off to bed suspicious
mari and mako proceed to patrol the
prison before declaring it inescapable
the next day meiko takes the boys to the
chairman's office meanwhile gaguto runs
inside the school causing the school
girls to beat him up as kyoshi declares
that they themselves have won mako
catches on to their roots and grabs joe
disguised as gakuto and chio disguised
under joe's hood kakuto is thrown into
the chairman's room by the students then
the boys explained that chio sneaked in
from the back door of the corrections
office where she met with gakuto and joe
inside the bathroom performing a
three-way exchange with each other's
clothes
in disguise gakuto made his way to the
corrections office enduring his cut from
the fork to have joe disguised with the
use of bandages gakuto hid himself
outside while mari and mako were
patrolling when meiko expresses
disbelief at how fast the dto email
would have been recovered gaguto tells
her of the data restoration software
being downloaded ahead of time during
the arm wrestling match as gakuto passes
the dto's information hard drive to the
chairman hana discovers kyoshi's
manipulation and proceeds to punch him
only to punch mari instead who holy
confesses to the dto plan
in a post-credits scene while the boys
seem content outside of their prison
lives the prison clad usc make their way
to the school prison they're charged by
the above brown student council the asc
news about their abusive incidents have
been spread around the school that's all
folks if you enjoyed this video hit the
like button and subscribe for more